Obrázok na obrazovke: Logo OzPlayer
Text na obrazovke: Čo je prístupnosť webu a ako sa premieta do online videí?
Text na obrazovke: Prečo nie sú súčasné videoprehrávače prístupné?
Text na obrazovke: Ako neprístupné videá ovplyvňujú koncových používateľov?
Text na obrazovke: 1) Klávesové pasce
Text na obrazovke: 2) Neprístupnosť klávesnicou
Text na obrazovke: 3) Automatické spúšťanie
Text na obrazovke: Čím sa OzPlayer líši od iných videoprehrávačov?
Text na obrazovke: Aké ďalšie problémy robia videoprehrávače neprístupnými?
Text na obrazovke: Ďalšie funkcie sú vo vývoji
Text na obrazovke: Aké funkcie by ste chceli vidieť?
Obrázok na obrazovke: Logo a URL Epic Photograpy & Video, www.epicphotography.com.au, hello@epicphotography.com.au
Text na obrazovke: Réžia: Charlotte Brentnall a Mark Fitzgerald
Strih: Mark Fitzgerald
Kamera: Mark Fitzgerald
Účinkuje: Gian Wild
Scenár: Charlotte Brentnall a Gian Wild
Obrázok na obrazovke: Logo OzPlayer